the film opens on a snowy winter night a
group of Travelers are stranded at a
remote train station unable to leave due
to the heavy snowfall inside the station
they huddle together for warmth and seek
solace in conversation suddenly they
notice the presence of a mysterious
stranger who is cloaked in a dark coat
his face obscured by dark sunglasses
intrigued by The Stranger presence The
Travelers invite him to share some
stories to pass time he begins by
narrating a chilling tale of a past
incident that unfolded high in the snow
covered mountains a plane crash rips
through the Silence of a remote Mountain
bodies lie scattered some dead and many
decapitated among the survivors an old
doct clutches his deceased wife
whispering to her for the last time a
businessman fueled by the instinct to
survive grabs a dead passenger's
belongings and urges everyone to follow
him he has a map promising a cabin
nearby Miss screams as her friend Mary's
leg is pinned beneath a seat the doctor
his heart heavy with his own loss
Springs into action he frees Mary
revealing a badly broken shin using a
salvaged rod from the wreckage he crafts
a makeshift splint driven by the urgency
of survival the survivors embark on a
treacherous Journey towards the cabin
the businessman burdened by carrying
Mary collapses under exhaustion he urges
the others to continue without him miss
looking back sees a horrifying sight the
businessman has placed Mary on the snow
and is digging a hole around her he says
he is making a bivwak where Mary might
have a chance to live he reminds them
that they do not have enough strength to
carry the injured Mary to the cabin as
missa watches on they are forced to make
the agonizing decision of burying Mary
alive leaving her to the mercy of the
mountain and the biting cold hope
flickers as they find the cabin offering
meager Comfort a stove blankets and a
ration of food M momentarily Tha by the
warmth is swept by a fresh wave of grief
for Mary Panic takes hold and she flings
open the door the wind extinguishing the
fire the reporter shovel in hand follows
her at the bivwak they find Mary
miraculously she has managed to crawl
out out her pale face emerging from the
snow still delirious from fever she
repeats that she is feeling hot the
reporter attempts to dig her out but the
shovel strikes Mary's neck blood stains
the snow as missa cries out in horror
Mary clutches Miss's scarf a final gasp
escaping her lips before the reporter
pulls them apart the businessman arrives
witnessing the scene he accuses the
reporter of murder and they all Retreat
back to the cabin inside the old doctor
questions Mary's absence the businessman
choosing to hide the truth claims she
died before they reached there the
doctor acknowledges the inevitability of
death in such dire circumstances
offering a somber acceptance he then
shifts the focus sharing a chilling tale
of two boys trapped in a tent by an
avalanche one healthy and cunning Fain
checking the weather to slowly consume
their supplies when the injured boy
succumbed he was buried outside but
horor awaited the Survivor each morning
his dead friend would be back in his
tent the old man leaves the story
hanging urging everyone to sleep knowing
sleep invites the risk of death from
from hypothermia they devise a plan
three will sleep while one stays awake
rotating every 5 minutes on the 10th
rotation the old man suggests waking
everyone the businessman hesitant at
first volunteers to stay awake first
during his watch he lights a cigarette
and sees a ghostly figure in white near
the wall convinced it's Mary he pleads
for forgiveness claiming his actions
were for her good but the alarm clock
shrill ring shatters the night and he
hastily wakes The Old Man and takes his
place in the bed the old man spends his
watch gazing at a photo of his deceased
wife a poignant reminder of his loss as
the alarm jolts him he wakes the
reporter then miss who watches old
videos of herself and Mary peers welling
up she Whispers an apology to her friend
suddenly the old man awakes with a start
the alarm beside him he Rouses everyone
and distributes their meager rations
missa notices a discrepancy she
confesses to falling asleep during her
turn revealing that the businessman
wasn't awakened by her confused and
unnerved the stranded passengers Ponder
The Impossible did someone else wake the
businessmen the chilling possibility of
Mary's Spirit lingers in the air
determined but wary they attempt to
sleep again with the reporter taking the
first watch however do we see a ghostly
figure in white crossing the room while
the reporter Slumbers the scene shifts
abruptly the old man is awakened again
the Alarm by his side he quickly Rouses
everyone but upon reaching the
businessman finds his body cold and
stiff two distinct marks Mar his neck
the doctor grimly declares he died at
least 2 hours ago p sets in his missa
And the reporter grapple with the
reality of Mary's vengeful Spirit
haunting them the usually calm doctor
unravels frantically consuming the
remaining bread refusing to sleep while
the others succumb to exhaustion soon
the old man to sees the girl in white a
shadowy hand emerges from the darkness
killing him alone with the horrifying
truth missa Whispers a chilling
realization they are all going to die
the reporter however refuses to
surrender he uses his camera to capture
their faces a defiant Act of resilience
amidst the incred approaching Darkness
slowly they drift off to sleep again
their fate hanging precariously in the
balance Miss awakens to another
nightmare the reporter lies dead an ax
protruding from his back with trembling
hands she grasps the camera recording a
final message accepting her fate she
prepares to face her end reviewing the
footage she sees a horrifying truth a
woman in white raises an Axe and plunges
it into the reporter's back but the
camera doesn't reveal the face of the
attacker Cara grips misses she begs for
forgiveness her voice echoing in the
silent cabin as the blanket slips from
her shoulders a shocking Revelation
emerges she wears a white dress
identical to the ghostly figure the hand
reaches out and grasps hers the scene
abruptly changes Rescuers find Mrs
screaming in the snow surrounded by the
bodies of the passengers the old man the
reporter the businessman in the distance
Mary's body remains untouched the shovel
still embedded in her neck the question
hangs heavy did missa kill them all or
was she a pawn of Mary's vengeful Spirit
we returned to the train station where
the Stranger In Black concludes the
story that the old doctor was telling
his fellow survivors he reveals that it
was the healthy boy who repeatedly dug
up his friend's body dragging it back to
his tent each night each morning
oblivious to his actions he buried the
body a new the young man eager for
another tale requests another story as
the camera Zooms in on the stranger
dressed in black coat a smile spreads
across the lips and he begins again The
Story begins with a black and white
scene depicting a historical event March
14th 17 2 morisano of the AKO Clan
assaults and injures Kira a member of
the shogunate within Ido Castle Bound by
the traditional Japanese rules of the
time asano commits harakiri an honorable
suicide to avoid punishment and disgrace
the burden of Revenge falls upon oi as's
chief minister yet initially oi shows
little interest in Vengeance preferring
to spend his time with his seductive
mistress one day a strange sound draws
oi's attention he investigates
discovering a silver box on the road
outside his home poking it with his
sword he is startled by a voice greeting
him from the other end it's a mobile
phone a technology unknown to the 18th
century Samurai initially skeptical oi's
disbelief Fades as the voice accurately
predicts the death of his adviser on
August 3rd 1702 The Voice reveals itself
as a historical researcher from the
future seeking confirmation of the
events of the past oi intrigued engages
in conversation with the phone much to
his wife's alarm she eventually leaves
with their children unable to the
unsettling presence of the Unseen voice
the researcher goess oi about his
planned attack on Kira questioning his
courage and motives oi's reluctance is
interpreted as a clever tactic to
mislead the enemy news reaches oi that
yamaka one of his Samurai has attempted
and failed to kill Kira oi instructs his
subordinate to join the attack and leave
him out feigning ignorance of the
incident later oi receives another call
while with his mistress he learns from
the researcher that his son disgusted by
his father's cowardice attempted to kill
him before joining the Revenge Mission
oi is saved only by the intervention of
the mobile phone dejected oi receives
another call the researcher presses him
to declare war on Kira reluctant at
first oi fabricates a rousing speech
declaring his loyalty to the samurai
spirit and his determination to avenge
Lord asano oi's words ignite the Flames
of rebellion among his clan his
reputation as a coward begins to shift
much to his annoyance the clan prepares
to attack Kira's residence on August
14th as the day of the attack approaches
oi grapples with his fear and doubts he
questions his own survival with the
researcher but receives no answer he
takes this as a confirmation of his
impending death oosi leads his men into
battle knowing they face certain death
he finds solace in the knowledge that
their sacrifice will be remembered
throughout history the story concludes
with the Revelation that the researcher
is just one of many who contact
historical figures to verify their
narratives Napoleon George Washington
and countless others have received
similar calls ensuring the accurate at
recording of History we cut back to the
train station the blizzard is still
raging hard outside not satisfied with
only two stories the passengers ask the
man in the black coat for another story
obliging with a smile he starts again in
a world where chess is a game devoid of
emotion where pieces are Mir ponds in
the pursuit of Victory Grandmaster Akira
faces his toughest opponent yet a
supercomputer the unbeaten genius
Grandmaster can calculate three
possibilities in one second however he
stands no chance in front of the
supercomputer super blue which can
calculate 200 million possibilities in a
single second Akira Falls to defeat his
world crumbling around him 3 years later
a disheveled Aira lies on the street
drunk and lost suddenly a car screeches
to a halt and two men emerge forcefully
carrying him inside they arrive at a
luxurious apartment its dark black walls
contrasting sharply with Akira's white
suit and shirt an old man dressed
entirely in Black awaits him he reveals
that Akira wants the undefeated Japanese
champion has vanished from the public
eye after losing to a supercomputer
rumors swirled of a comfortable life
abroad but the reality is far Grimmer
the old man Demands a chess game a way
for Akira to repay the money lost after
betting on his victory Akira haunted by
his defeat refuses the old man taunts
him claiming refusal is accepting defeat
and moves to remove the white king from
the board fueled by bruised ego Akira
stops him without even looking at the
board He commands the pawn to move to D4
initiating the game he remains standing
refusing to face the board directly
claiming he doesn't need to see to play
against an amateur the old man counters
stating that the lives in this city are
a game of chess with far greater
consequences than losing a simple match
as Akira recounts his feelings after his
historic loss he glances out the window
a horrifying scene unfolds people
dressed in white in black suits
mirroring the chess game their movements
eerily synchronized as the black pawn
takes the white Pawn a man in Black
brutally kills a man in white mimicking
the move on the board horrified by the
brutal act Akira rushes down to find the
victim a dagger protruding from his
abdomen later he sits with his
psychiatrist Dr OTA clad in a white
apron Akira confesses the recent
happenings but Dr OTA assures him it's
just a figment of his imagination
suddenly aax arrives bearing the image
of the chessboard from Akira's game
against the old man frantic Akira shouts
at the next move for his Pawn only to
receive another fact this time it shows
The Black Queen closing in on the white
night before Akira's eyes Dr OTA
collapses and dies as he calls for help
Akira notices a photograph on the wall
Dr OTA horseback riding mirroring the
position of the Night On The Board a
chilling voice pierces the air a nurse
dressed impeccably in black her hair
tied in a bun reminiscent of the queen
enters and asks Akira what will your
next move be Panic stricken Akira flees
into the lobby but the old man's
henchmen relentlessly pursue him
demanding his next move he finds himself
in a parking lot surrounded by white
cars he enters one its keychain
curiously shaped like a bishop the car
however defies his control sliding
sideways despite his attempts to drive
straight he exits and approaches another
car it's keychain shaped like a rook but
before he can start the car he realizes
this move is illegal as he has already
moved his Bishop suddenly a black car
slams into his mirroring the black Rook
taking the white Rook Akira comes to the
horrifying realization that his castle
his home in the real world is now lost
realizing his wife the queen is an
imminent danger Akira rushes back to the
old millionaire and begs to quit the old
man reminds him that quitting means
accepting defeat and losing the crown a
determined Akira despite his
disadvantage in the game he had
neglected regains his Focus drawing from
his past as a world champion he quickly
Maneuvers himself into a position for a
two-step Checkmate acknowledging his own
disadvantage the old man asks Akira if
he is willing to sacrifice to win
blindfolded Akira finds himself in an
arena with a life-sized chessboard and
pieces he is the white king facing the
old man as the black king Akira is
poised to win but only by sacrificing
his Queen his wife the black Rook stands
poised to strike yet Akira chooses to
lose the game and sacrifice himself
putting himself in the rook's path The
Rook wielding a dagger plunges into his
chest as Akira Falls seemingly defeated
he sees all the Fallen pieces rise and
applaud to his astonishment he is
unharmed the dagger a mere prop Dr OTA
reveals this elaborate scenario was a
for of shock therapy designed to
reignite Akira's passion for the game
the old man dressed in black millionaire
aaki the sponsor who funded the creation
of super blue is also revealed to be
part of the plan though Akira lost the
game he feels no bitterness he realizes
that there are things far more important
than chess like his relationship with
his wife hayaki further reveals that
super blue unable to process Akira's
self-sacrificing mooved to save his
Queen has overheated and fried its
systems the film concludes with Akira's
poignant de decaration chess is a game
of emotion where all the pieces play as
a team we return back to the train
station The Stranger In Black fixes his
Gaze on a young couple excitedly
planning their wedding he then begins
his next story under a rainy Sky a young
woman named Maru takes cover outside a
movie theater suddenly a young man named
UI jumps out of a bus and rushes towards
her escaping the rain after a short
conversation about the weather UI
impulsively buys two movie tickets Maru
is surprised but before she can answer
they are all already heading into the
theater fast forward to their wedding
planning the marriage company has
different packages where they receive
different gifts at different
anniversaries after marriage on the 10th
anniversary They will receive a
videotape from their better halves that
is recorded in the present day while
talking about all these packages the
couple stumbles Upon A Futuristic
package a marriage simulator that offers
a glimpse into their future married life
intrigued they agree to the test the
scientist explains that the simulator
analyzes their DNA backgrounds and
person personalities to create a
personalized simulation however their
future is not a fixed script but rather
a dynamic experience shaped by their
emotional responses nervously Maru and
yui enter the simulator they find
themselves one year into their marriage
living a comfortable life but
occasionally clashing over small issues
during a break in the simulation UI
reassures Mara that he will always be by
her side however on their way back they
witness another couple arguing after
their simulation showed the man
potentially cheating back in the
simulation Maru and yui are preparing
for the arrival of their baby they
pre-select names Haruki for a boy and
Yuka for a girl to their surprise ui's
mother steps in and names their newborn
son yiro citing family tradition
frustrated Maru lashes out at UI for
breaking their agreement the scene jumps
to their 10th anniversary Maru is angry
that UI is constantly busy with work and
neglects her he defensively replies that
he works hard to provide for her and
their son years later Mara decides to
join the workforce Yi reluctantly agrees
but suggests they move in with his
parents for their son's sake Maru
rejects this idea accusing him of always
believing he makes the bigger sacrifices
the tension escalates leading to a
heated argument and a decision to
divorce suddenly they wake up from the
simulation Maru shaken and tearful slaps
UI for breaking his promise to stay with
her he stubbornly argues that it's
better they discovered the potential
problems before marriage the couple
cancels their wedding plans and goes
their separate ways Maru focuses on her
career and enjoys her independence one
day she receives a package from The
Marriage Company inside is a videotape
UI pre-recorded for their 10th
anniversary hesitant at first Maru
eventually plays the tape the younger UI
Reveals His struggles with shyness and
difficulty expressing his emotions he
apologizes for the potential troubles he
might cause in their marriage UI then
confesses that their first encounter at
the theater wasn't just chance he had
noticed Mara before but never dared to
talk to her he admits that he pretended
not to have an umbrella just to have a
reason to approach her with sincerity UI
says that no matter how bad his day is
seeing maru's face always brings him Joy
he proposes celebrating their 10th
anniversary by returning to the theater
where they met overwhelmed with emotion
Maru rushes to the theater and finds UI
waiting with two tickets they Embrace
realizing that love can overcome
challenges and bind them together in the
final scene we learned that the couple
was still within the simulation the
entire experience from Marriage to
conflict to reconciliation served as a
test of their commitment and love hand
in hand they face the future knowing
that while difficulties are inevitable
their love will guide them through in
the last scene of the movie we return to
the train station where the blizzard has
finally stopped four of The Travelers
leave while The Stranger In Black gears
updo tell another story to the last
remaining passenger